this is a production of Cornell
University
thank you very much for coming and
joining in the discussion on on biochar
and what it is and why why maybe it
deserves a second look
so of course difficult to to get it all
aspects of of biochar there's quite a
bit to talk about and you'll learn why
and what angles are important but I'll
I'll start early I'll start a few
hundred years ago that biochar interest
is actually not anything new it seems
there was under the name of charcoal
mostly or other materials an interest in
in applying char or charcoal from very
early times onwards there are some
literature points here this is in
Japanese an encyclopedia of Agriculture
then there was the Terra Preta discovery
quote/unquote starting with Orellana who
described fertile soils in the Amazon
where others didn't find anything and
and then there were some folks in the
late 1880s to look at terra preta
but also in our area charcoal use Alan
this is a also an agricultural standard
book from the mid 1800s mazed mentions
charcoal as a soil amendment and
uselessly Beck also mentions it real
research only happened starting in the
early 1900s and here with with pine
seedlings with and without charcoal or
biochar and they described some
reductions in damping off and but
nothing really serious though there were
actually some some products that were
self assault and this is of course
interesting for horticulture because of
course that the turf gets a lot better
and the bad ball bounces better and
whatever and this is some kind of slang
that I I don't pretend to be able to
reproduce here but there were actual
companies in the 30s 20s 30s that sold
charcoal products for soil amendment and
that pretty much disappeared and you can
speculate why some of those disappeared
with the advent of chemical
fertilization are not relying so much on
on other strategies but it's slowly the
that's shifting a little bit and it's
not only with biochar but others
amendments as well so my story become
began with these soils as was mentioned
in the introduction these are the Terra
Preta soils in the Amazon if you can see
these the color is quite different of
these adjacent soils there might be just
tens of meters away from each other and
this being the Terra Preta so very very
dark far down in some instances up to
two or three meters down very black
soils whereas those are the the adjacent
soils and of course they're they're much
more fertile these black parts as the
same guy same height same day so you see
that that the corn here is a lot shorter
and this is a was a study that was
controlling for the age of the secondary
vegetation that was cleared before the
trial started and and the darkness here
is from char compounds and that was
proven in the late 90s why they are so
dark is is from there a lot of other
things happened with Terra Preta and
that's why it's not a perfect study
object for the effects of char because
there are a lot of other things that
happen these are on triple G and excels
that received a lot of other things as
well but I studied in the time when
these experiments were done in the in
the Amazon and got interested in in
looking at this a little bit further but
there is also a Cornell story that
reaches back over a hundred years with
this guy all of you know of course it's
Charles Hart you might not know it he's
happened to be a geology professor here
he was the first chair of the geology
department in the 1870s and he wrote a
book
the geology and physical geography of
Brazil for the first time that we think
it has been scientifically described the
Terra Preta more so by his graduate
student at Cornell grad Herbert Smith in
his book the Amazons and the coast so
there's a there's a Cornell and just for
for a fun factor this is a early slide
early PowerPoint from from Charles Hart
he painted it himself and and this is a
canvas that's now in the Croft library
that's about the size of this whole
front front panel here so this is this
is what a hundred years ago the
professors would would roll up and and
show you
exercise out of it probably so they're
about I think five or six of these huge
canvases in the Croft library first when
I try to find them and take photos of
them they couldn't find them again
because they were so big they had to
store them somewhere underneath some
some racks and couldn't find them so
biochar interest has emerged the term
itself only came about in 2006 through
two of our publications and and here in
Google Trends if you want to believe
these gained some prominence in the
public domain so was spoken about if you
if you compared with the hits that
bioenergy got in in comparison to
biochar so there was some some great
interest luckily it has died down a
little bit which afforded us the
opportunity to do science and not do
public relations and science we did we
is the capital we well we all you some
of you we as a scientific community if
you look at the number of publications
since 2002 dabbling around just a
handful each year mostly under the name
of charcoal but then in relation to of
soil application and showed up the last
couple of years
tremendously and now the red dots show
that the proportion of biochar research
and charcoal research as a fraction of
compost so we're sort of at half or a
little bit above half the publication
volume that is happening in compost so
that's quite a bit
chief over the last two or three years
considering that most research has only
started about in this year to get funds
or allocate some of their existing funds
to biochar research and and and we'll
probably see a tremendous increase
because most universities in the US are
now having at least one program in
Ambala research and these are some some
reports this is our book that we wrote
in 2000 and polished in 2008 so you can
see a lot of the information that is
contained in these in these publications
is probably now redundant because most
of the peer-reviewed publications became
available only afterwards but biochar is
actually not really a material that
sounds a bit odd but it's actually a
system of how we deal with organic
matter and nutrients in an agricultural
landscape it's more than just a material
that are buying a bag and put put in the
soil because you you might have an
interest in biochar because it's
actually a waste management strategy in
that that's maybe one of the older ones
there are pyrolysis unit units four have
been built for decades that are waste
management tools to to get rid of
certain wastes and intensify them and
then landfill them or do something with
it so it might be a waste management
tool it might afford you the possibility
of mitigating climate change but else I
show you there's much more to that than
just producing biochar you can actually
accelerate and emit carbon dioxide net
carbon dioxide and and greenhouse gases
by producing biochar so it's a systems
question you might produce energy as at
the same time as you produce biochar
because the off gases that coming off
during pyrolysis can be used as an
energy carrier and it might lead to Sol
improvement and the question is always
where where are you do you need to
harness all of these benefits to be
sustainable and have social and
financial
that you need to be in here or or can
you be out here in any of those two to
make it work we'll talk a bit more about
because of the audience and you're
likely interest about the biochar
product something that we might put to
soil and have expectations of soil
improvement we probably are likely also
interested in stability of that material
because that's one of the charms of
biochar if it's improves the soil it
might do so for a very long period of
time
so that might be interesting and just to
set the stage for what biochar is it's
it's really a fundamental change in
chemistry making biochar or char out of
biomass the color changes now these
hazel nut shells become black you
fundamentally change the chemical makeup
into something that's much more aromatic
though very heterogeneous compounds
there might be not perfect structures
highly interlinked and as the
temperature increases especially beyond
600 degrees you see then more orders
coming up to burst radix so-called super
static carbon increasing and and again
changing the structure of the carbon at
very high temperatures which might not
be relevant for biochars a soil
amendment you might find a highly
ordered structure but that that happens
only in the thousands of whereas the
chemistry really fundamentally changes
completely changes the morphology as you
can see the hazelnut shells still look
like hazelnut shells they're black a
banana would still look like banana
they're people who do that they try that
out it still looks like and
microscopically is actually also to
certain against extent that the
morphology looks like the the original
material so you can still see there's I
limbs flames you see all the plant
structures so what you put in you get
out the dimensions might be a little bit
different the chemistry of the minerals
might change and definitely a chemistry
of the carbon changes
and one of the profound changes are the
the stoichiometry between oxygen and
carbon and oxygen and carbon and
hydrogen
you devala ties and condense the carbon
structures with increasing temperature
you decrease both the HC and the OC
ratios towards something that's carbon
rich and oxygen and hydrogen poor and
you see that no more or less everything
is on a straight line here with greater
temperature increase in there's a good
relationship apart from these bars up
here that that look very very different
and these are the the oddballs biochar
made from paper sludge biochar made from
poultry so high mineral high mineral
feedstocks and and lowliness feedstocks
that are falling out so there's a there
is still apart from the fact that that
several are lining up very nicely and we
can describe them very well there are
quite a there is still quite a variety
and some of them might fall out so we we
definitely need to understand better
what the formation conditions of these
kind of biochar is and and whether they
are of any use as as a soil amendment
I saw a conditioner we have much more
experience with woody materials the the
volatile compound which is a measure a
laboratory measure of the thermal
stability which has often been equated
to also recalcitrant against microbial
decomposition correlate somewhat with
the HC and OC ratios and and works quite
well but again here we see that that
some of the other see these odd ones
paper poultry are falling out of these
equations but this affords us the
possibility to analytically distinguish
those wares for the OC n HC ratios that
was not really possible they overlapped
with this technique we can actually
separate analytically materials that
have high so called volatile contents
from those that have lower volatile
and then work with stoichiometry to
understand for instance stability a bit
better so we understand that there's a
huge variation in in properties with
these comparatively simple analytical
tools and and here you see it's in a
different way
ash content alone you see we have some
materials here from paper mill of
poultry for instance that have 50% and
more ash content to some woody materials
that have barely any ash content the
fixed carbon or volatiles
which is not a subtraction of one of the
other they add up to a hundred percent
you'll you'll see that we might have no
fixed carbon and only volatile carbon in
some whereas we have more than 60% in
others and the temperature plays a big
role
increasing pyrolysis temperature from
300 to 600 degrees you can see typically
increases the so called fixed carbon
content and decreases the volatile
carbon content
so both feedstock and temperature of
formation play a big role in and what
the biochar looks like and feedstock
plays a huge role for for the ash
content so we have a huge variety of
different materials if we map this out
on such a triangle that we are familiar
with very often from from soil texture
analysis and map out volatiles ash and
fixed carbon content and that the arrows
always point from the lowest formation
temperature to the highest formation
temperature will see that we we increase
the fixed carbon content and decrease
the volatile carbon content with higher
temperature but that changes that
trajectory actually changes with high
ash material so something's happening
it's not only just more ash in some of
the biochars but the ash content has a
profound effect on the organic chemical
composition of the of the entire biochar
so it's not just more nutrients or ashes
silica in in some biochars so likely
also the the material itself the carbon
material itself is fundamentally
different when you have high ash content
and and that's nicely shown in here so
we have a lot of variety between
different biochars but we unfortunately
also have a lot of variation within the
biochar this might be a mock-up of a
biochar particle imagine that to be a
few micrometer large and then you have
probably more ordered structures more
folded structures you might have some
organic matter absorbed to it some
microorganisms here so there's there's a
huge amount of variation also within
each each biochar on that that causes
challenges for us for characterization
but also it causes a challenges for us
for understanding what actually how we
actually might explain some of the
effects that we see on a microcosm or or
a field level when you char you you
transform the carbon but you also do
something with the nutrients the maybe
most interesting one is of course
nitrogen we manage organic matter very
often with the intent of men in managing
nitrogen and very often we do that
because we like to add some organic
nitrogen that hopefully will be
available for a plant to take up and
improve crop yields that's of course
very different for char when we do a
thermo chemical conversion the a lot of
the the nitrogen might volatilize
because we're doing a thermo chemical
conversion during that thermochemical
conversion but funny enough that that is
very different for different organic
materials a pine that is low in nitrogen
actually the nitrogen content increase
the yield ratio increases so we're
getting more nitrogen in the in the
biochar
in relation to carbon whereas with with
a high nitrogen containing poultry
litter for instance we're getting a net
loss compared in relation to carbon so
they're they're interesting things
happening and we're just now with one
PhD student looking at what what these
nitrogen compounds look like and and and
how they might be available and and our
expectations is of course that the
nitrogen content is it's not very well
available and and that we largely lock
up nitrogen in in highly recalcitrant
compounds which poses a challenge for
the overall nitrogen balance of an
agricultural ecosystem counterbalance
something that that I won't be getting
into much today is that we very often
found find increased nitrogen use
efficiency so the nitrogen that we
actually add to the soil is taken up by
a to a greater extent by crops in the
presence of biochar through retention
mechanisms a big portion of the
attraction as I mentioned earlier is the
stability and and I'll only go into this
quickly and I could have a whole a whole
seminar just on stability but what we
can walk away with is that typically
biochar is an order or more more stable
than the uncharged precursor material
there might be some exceptions paper
sludge might be one but typically the
uncharred is a is much more labile
against microbial decay but we have some
issues in in in characterizing that and
we showed you some some results from
proximate analysis OSI agency ratios
there's some fancier spectroscopic
techniques that we employ to instill
some confidence because that is of
course a big discussion item how sure
are we and how can we demonstrate it for
a given material how stable that is how
this leads to climate change mitigation
is you need to think about it it's it's
as I said it's not just the biochar
itself it's the it's a systems
management it in a in a normal system
without charring or fires we would have
some fixation of co2 by photosynthesis
some Auto respiration organic material
through route turnover or leaf litter
fall would get get into the soil and
then in a equilibrium on an annual cycle
probably be mineralized to the same
degree as as it is getting into the soil
but so what if we conceive a biochar
system we would look at using the
material that would otherwise in the
same time frame mineralized and paralyze
it in something that's much more stable
added to the soil half of it we would
hopefully in many systems use as
bioenergy and offset fossil fuels or
other Woodmont or other biomass that
would otherwise be used and added to the
soil which in which it would remain for
a lot much longer period of time which
would mean a decrease in emissions and
therefore a net carbon withdrawal from
the atmosphere so important is to
realize that still the the co2
withdrawal or the co2 capture from the
atmosphere is delivered by the growing
plant all we can hope to do is decrease
the return of co2 to the atmosphere by
deviating some of the fast cycling
biological carbon cycle in a much slower
cycling biochar sort of geological
carbon cycle and we do have choices if
we are starting with a hundred percent
of our initial carbon stock and just let
the tree grow for instance or the
vegetation growth we might get still not
a bigger tree over time and anything we
do if the baseline scenario was growing
the tree we would of course emit carbon
so we have to use opportunities where
we're in
under a baseline scenario the carbon
would be emitted so we we're looking
down at for instance a decay of a fresh
biomass maybe woody biomass or this
orange Uihlein fresh by mesh aberrations
or crop residues field crops or
horticultural crops that would decompose
very quickly over time if we char we
immediately volatilize about half of the
carbon but the remaining carbon is in in
most cases much more stable than the
than the biomass carbon and although we
have had here 100 percent and here only
50 percent at time zero we would
probably after some time and that
depends very much on the unreliability
of our original material have more
carbon in soil than under the baseline
scenario but you see that there are big
differences whether we have this
baseline scenario this one or that one
and we need to recognize that even if we
have identified an opportunity to have a
net carbon sequestration we still
probably dealing with different turnover
time so mean residence times and
depending on the mean residence time we
will have eventually a scenario where we
where we will have more net
mineralization than we can net sequester
and that's illustrated here just
theoretically with with made up data
just model data but which illustrates
that just fine here the the net
sequestration effect of biochar
scenarios where the biochar has a mean
residence time of 50 years 100 years 200
500 a thousand 10,000 years and you'll
see that as a fraction of what we might
apply as an annual maximum we would see
that we would under a scenario of 500
years mean residence time we would reach
peak biocharge
somewhere around 50 6070 years
and then have a slightly declining net
sequestration only if we have really
high mean residence times and this is
considered a very high one would we have
this for very long hundreds of years so
we're looking probably at a strategy
from simply the mean residence times as
something that helps us transition out
of out of a fossil fuel future into
something else but it's not a perpetual
strategy for the next hundreds of years
another layer of complexity is that it's
of course not even only the the biomass
that we use and the stability of the
biochar itself but there are a lot of
other points in in a biochar system that
might generate or reduce climate gas
emissions and and that that might be
with transportation might have to do
with transportation avoided emissions
from biomass decay the energy that you
produce transport tillage soil carbon
changes and so on and so forth so we try
to put this all into a big model and
have published a few that just looked at
the lifecycle of individual project but
also some that looked at at this at the
global scale and this is the global
scale analysis I was published a couple
of years ago and what we came away with
as a maximum sustainable technical
potential that's really if you did that
all over the place as much as we thought
with quite conservative yet quite
ambitious assumptions so discounting
discounting if you had to have salt
protection discounting biomass
availability for and used for other
purposes we came away with somewhere in
the one Gigaton annual emission
reductions which is not insignificant
but it will not it's not it's it's about
an order of magnitude or not quite an
order of magnitude off the total
emissions of
the fossil fuel so on its own it will
not save the day
but it's not as a package with another
20 or so sequestration emission
reduction strategies it it might play in
there something to point out also is the
dashed lines are comparative scenarios
if we use biomass for for combustion and
an energy generation you'll see they're
always below the equivalent straight
line or filled line and the reason for
that is that the difference is really
the soil effects of the biochar if there
were no soil effects of biochar either
reduced gas emissions improved growth or
any of that we they would overlay over
each other so we have to have a soil
effect but at the end of the day and
this is a survey that we did for
projects that were are conducted in
developing countries and it's it's
already a one and a half years old we
asked for this World Bank report that's
still not out projects existing projects
that that was selected from 150 projects
down to at the end it was was somewhere
around 50 projects how important carbon
sequestration or carbon credits and
mitigation of climate change was to
their project and there was only a
quarter of the project that said it's
it's really important the other set not
important at all oh yeah we'll take it
but we don't count on it
so and I think that's that's the
sentiment throughout a lot of different
project that have to do with mitigation
of climate change it that other
ecosystem services and agronomic
improvements are topping climate
mitigation incentives and because carbon
credits are are not really anything that
anybody counts on at the moment so why
biochar is added to soil in the US and
then northeast of the yeses is mainly
because farmers
landscapers are interested in in their
improvements in improvements or of
growth or other factors there are now
companies that look at green roofs
companies who look at turf there
companies who look at greenhouse
operations and a few horticultural crops
and and field crops here just a way of
thinking through through some of the
issues with a growth experiment that we
did here in the in the in the greenhouse
with soils from from the musgrave
experimental farm where we looked at
different temperatures of formation
different feedstocks and gave that to a
Amaze crop and and here you see biochar
added at different rates 0.2 0.5 to and
7 percent by weight which equates
somewhat to about 2 tons per hectare 5
20 and 70 and and the biomass production
of the corn in comparison to the dashed
line which is the control and you can
see that there's a wide spread this is
for 300 degrees Celsius for these kind
of different feedstocks and we did more
of those at different other feedstocks
wouldn't and crop residues but a seed
from from a significant increase from a
40 50 percent increase to almost a
complete die-off with everything so it
can do almost anything you can kill
plants and you can improve crop growth
quite dramatically
so obviously and all of that we would
maybe call biochar so obviously we need
to understand a little bit why one kills
the plant and the other one that's just
great
and is there really anything that we
know goes beyond very simple
explanations that we might achieve with
a lot of other management interventions
as well with with an analysis of
variance and just do some statistics now
some feed stocks come out on top poultry
manure and and likely that has a lot of
nutrients in it
waste so whatever the Cornell students
and faculty I guess don't eat is it's
doing really poorly so but we don't eat
we we shan't give to plants as
temperature has a significant effect 500
degree Celsius was the best but no
without dwelling on this too much all
the interactions yeah that's a plant
growth again sorry that's a gram of of
plants in the pot yeah good questions
thanks but before we draw too much on it
all the interactions are also
significant so you can you can have
something so the average is over over
all feedstocks are are almost
meaningless because you you might have a
different feedstock might have a very
different temperature of all the
interactions were were significant so
it's a a highly complex response that
that defies simple simple regressions
and simple and then we tried a few other
conversion processes that the blue ones
are all the ones that I showed you with
the feedstocks but we tried also from
collaborators updraft fast pyrolysis
flash pyrolysis gasification Tora
faction and through in an activated
carbon from Japanese colleagues that
that they put in hundreds of of golf
courses in Japan so they're going every
few years and put that stuff in in golf
courses and you'll see that no that's
this didn't do all that well compared to
the control which is the yellow one this
is again total biomass in that pot of
maize and and you can see that there's
no clear picture that all the
gasification czar doing well and
although the slow pyrolysis star doing
bad although it orders somewhat with
with with feedstock all that poultries
are are on the left side and all the
foods are on the right side so there's
there's somewhat a pattern
the problem with the food was mainly a
problem of of sodium we found that a lot
of the food waste had a lot of sodium no
we we put too much salt on our on our
food we know that we shouldn't do it and
we definitely shouldn't do it if we want
to put it in the soil but of course also
that might be managed either because you
might put less of it on 0.2% was just
fine it didn't decrease anything you
might not put 70 tonnes on which nobody
would dream of putting on anyways or or
the sodium might leach out very quickly
with the first rain event or might be
post treated in some ways but it's
definitely something to consider we
tried to correlate that with with
different parameters we thought maybe
that the soils the the specific soil
surface surface area would have anything
to do with the the ability of the chars
to improve some growth parameter didn't
really come out th not only mildly none
of these parameters that I showed you
earlier carbon nitrogen also not really
if anything then it was negative so
there were some weak positive
correlations with nutrient contents and
then the negative correlation with with
sodium so we didn't really find a simple
a simple reason why some of the plants
grew well and and others didn't sort of
reflecting the the mix of different
responses that we saw to two input
variables of temperature and and
feedstock a good example why this is
this is not the end of the story is is
always pH which is a very simple way of
showing the the potential of of
manipulating and maybe designing
different biochars for different options
or different salt constraints and and
you see here the ash content versus the
pH measured in
Dasom chloride for all our chars and we
group them here together
oops we don't need and and you'll see
that there's quite a big spread here we
can produce bio charts with a pH of
close to four we actually have sometimes
produced it at four or below and and
close to 12 that's that's a huge spread
and you all know so else that we don't
want them here have here or here we want
to have them somewhere in the middle
here so they're down opportunities and
NS you see here again the arrows point
from the lowest temperature pyrolysis
temperature of the same feedstock to the
highest we can produce biochars from the
same feedstock that have I other pH of
four or five or or seven or eight so
even even if we are locked into a
certain feedstock we might have the
possibility to change our biochar
product quite significantly and that's
that's not not a bad way of manipulating
our organic matter amendments that's
very different to compost for instance
we probably get one type of compost out
when we make compost and it has a
certain pH it might be of poor quality
of higher quality but the ability to to
change when we have a certain type of
feedstock input to change the output is
is very difficult and and and with
managing compost is also not that easy
whereas conceivably and it's all not
doesn't work always that way conceivably
we can dial in a certain temperature
quite precisely and produce a biochar of
a very specific type agronomic effects
might differ not only with the biochar
type but also with the soil it's very
clear although some users and and those
not so familiar with with soil science
and an agronomy tend to forget that I
won't insult you with this with these
negligence but it's very clear that on a
feral soul if you put something on a
biochar with a pH of nine or a
it you get a significant positive
response simply for pH effect and there
might be other things happening but but
I would claim that this is probably a
lot of it as a pH effect whereas on the
calc aerosol the the wheat will probably
not respond to it or even go down and
the same with soybean so we really need
to start with a with the soil
constraints if we if we identify a soil
constraint and we think that biochar can
do something about it and we need to
produce the biochar that actually can do
it if we had put a put a biochar with a
pH of 3 on this this would also maybe
not have grown any better so we need to
we need to really design biochars to the
soil constraints that we identify that's
the easy one the pH and and the pH of
the soil and and how it might address
acidity or alkalinity and not chop more
interesting and complex are the effects
of biochar on nutrient leaching here is
an experiment from a Mali Seoul from
Iowa where biochar was added these are
the the different additions with high
additions of 20 tons 10 5 0 other with
manure
additions which is the filled symbols or
without manure additions and you can see
when you add manure you have a lot of
phosphorus leaching but the more biochar
you add this phosphorus leaching goes
dramatically down so it seems that there
might be mechanisms and we've we've
shown that there's a high Acadian
exchange capacity on on chars per unit
surface area per unit mass then any
other organic matter that we have looked
at so there are opportunities to retain
cations obviously a phosphate is not a
cation but an anion so there there are
other things going on could be calcium
phosphate formation could be calcium
bridge in a hydrogen bridging could be
something else this is not yet known
while working on that to find out a bit
more we can have exactly the opposite
and this is
and marks data from from turf here at
Cornell marks thesis looking at biochar
that was made from from turf chart and a
sand control and and Pete so the the
gold standard and you can see with with
Pete compared to the sand control
leaching go and went down but with
biochar it went up quite a bit so the
opposite of what we showed earlier
well this biochar it turns out has a
huge amount of phosphorous in it already
so it if it actually didn't retain any
phosphorus that contributed phosphorus
the grass grew a lot greener and better
so that went very well and there were
some interesting effects on on on
disease but it was definitely not useful
to reduce phosphorus leaching so again
we need to also for that we need to know
we need to know our biochar I guess
there are fancier things going on
interesting the disease severity these
are colleagues from from Israel they
have now two or three papers on this
different diseases and they consistently
find reduction of disease and they
looked at different diseases of in
different plants I don't quite remember
what this is just a placeholder but they
found with 0 3 & 5 percent a significant
reduction in disease severity and and
they try to link that to a change in
microbial and microbial associations in
the rhizosphere that no they think
judging from other papers might have an
effect on systemic with resistance of so
that's those are a few interesting leads
worth following up on
with eric nelson together we've done
some preliminary tries with Pythium here
in Plant Pathology and and he also find
or if he finds with with a soil borne
disease
the perfume that we have lower disease
severity with with biochars and we're
currently clueless of why that is and we
of course don't trust our results until
we know why we why we find that in
another attack we are trying to
understand whether we can produce
inoculant carriers based on earlier
results no this is from their from the
80s but their results from the 30s and
40s
we're very often in optimum carriers
were used that were based on on charcoal
Peters of course the gold standard now
especially Australian Pete as an
inoculum carrier for Rhizobium and and
you can see that the biochar was as good
as as the gold standard Pete over this
120 days and we have a project that that
looks at that these are some early
results from that some NPN numbers from
biochars made from from pine at 450
degrees from oak at 700 and oak at 450
compared to the peat so the Pete did
very well so we didn't screw up anything
but initially we did but this this
worked out very well so these are
acceptable values these are good values
but you see we can also again we can
choose a biochar that really backfired
and and these are acts unacceptable
numbers is a log scale so these are
really low numbers for microbials
rhizobia survival but these are very
good numbers and of course there might
be opportunities because the biochar
that we might produce this is instantly
sterile at 450 degrees and not a lot of
microorganisms that survived that
whereas the peat you have to autoclave
and that might be an Allen gin in in
some countries let alone to get
Australian peat in some locations might
be a challenge and it's a non-renewable
resource that is only to increase in
price so there are there are some
opportunities for for such project
products which of course are very small
and specialized markets
because it's also so different of the
the biochars we really need to have a
framework for it we founded the
International biochar initiative a while
back five six years or so and went
through a guidelines exercise in the
past a couple of years where we try to
define what biochar is because there are
people who put but use old tires and and
paralyze them and call that biochar and
all sorts of things and and of course
there's there's no no definition nobody
has defined the term officially we tried
but nobody listens if just their their
individual scientists writing papers so
we try to come up with standards and
want to in the future develop also
sustainability standards for systems so
this is where we are reviewed criteria
had in-depth reviews their webinars that
were held in two waves there was public
and commenting period so very much
modeled after ISO and other
international standards and trying now
this year to provide a first version of
it and there are different levels of
stringency of characterizations that we
that we propose and I don't want to go
into detail the FE one at category a is
know the amount of carbon how much
carbon is there in in biochar that would
exclude some and what's the HC ratio and
that will exclude others and that's
become a big contentious discussion
because some producers and also
researchers of course have have
different opinions about that so it was
very interesting to see how we can have
different consensus and international
consensus on that and then there are
obvious
PAHs and fir'aun's dioxins levels but
very often these are not even published
for composts so it's very hard to come
up with some of these levels
Micra new heavy metals again there are
some by their compost guidelines but but
also not as straightforward as you would
think they are here you see that
temperature affects the HC ratio of the
biochars with increasing temperature low
HC ratio as we've seen earlier and 0.7
you'll see that that will include some
of the black dots here where where
should that limit be at the moment at
0.7 so anything above would not qualify
as a biochar according to these these
standards and Australia is is using a
different approach they're using a
recovery of 20% so they're looking more
at the system not as a biochar property
not as as a material property but more
systems recovery of carbon throughout
the pyrolysis process very different
approach so just briefly a few a few
pictures rather of biochar production so
this is of course charcoal production
from way back when this is not a good
way of doing it right this is how it
happened very very of course throughout
upstate New York in the 1800s most of
those were abandoned in in the 1880s
when we switched completely - anthracite
for pig iron production but that's why
we have decreased our our forests here
so dramatically in the 1800's because of
of this process this is of course all in
it this lost energy we get only thirty
twenty to thirty percent charcoal out of
one hundred percent
biomass the rest is smoke but it's all
energy that we can capture this is a
unit from three are and in hung Hungary
that are coming out of the waste
management area so they are producing
biochar for soil amendment they are
certified now they can sell that in the
EU they have had trials in three
countries in the EU so they have a
marketable product right now they don't
capture energy this is a small pilot
project in Australia
that actually produces electricity while
making biochar
this is a first project although I think
of a third generation of an NGO NGO
called prana Torah founded in Brazil
originally here in Senegal with a unit
that produces biochar made from from
invasive wheat wheat along the Senegal
River and this is a biochar production
in in British Columbia from a lot of the
pine pine beetle kill so this is a
mobile unit comes on a on a semi in the
back and can produce no biochar where
wherever these kills are as a baseline
scenario in comparison to just flaring
them up because that's what they doing
currently so those are some technology
solutions that we might look at we are
looking at building units that are
smaller than what you've just seen well
it might be about this size a bit bigger
actually than this size we're currently
with working with the engineers and a
couple projects to model the flows of
gases and and the combustion through
through such a system where materials
fed in and then transported through full
gas recycling for the second generation
the first generation will be much
simpler and this is what what such a
unit will look like we and some of you
have might have seen that in Leland Hall
here up the road we were able with with
lots of support and and and goodwill to
renovate a portion of the Leland
facility with all kinds of safety things
now we can imagine a New York State is
about the worst place maybe California
is even worse but in terms of
regulations to comply with all kinds of
things that they put their put sprinkler
sprinklers in that that I probably would
be fine for nuclear disaster so it's
it's amazing what we had to put in this
facility for this little thing but
there's that's quite a bit to do and
building such a facility here being able
to produce maybe hundreds of kilos of of
biochar per day
in a week and staging field trials is an
ability where we can understand a bit
better what the crop and and and plant
effects are beyond this simple ones pH
carrion retention and the simple
nutrient additions I think now it's time
to do some adaptive science their their
initiatives also here in the finger as
Finger Lakes biochar groups there are
northeast biochar groups they're all
cropping up and they're all doing
starting to produce biochar and their
biochar didn't manage to do that but
they came by biochar with within a
package on amazon.com and of course we
we don't know what's in there
and nobody will tell us either but we
need to we need to look at what that
does for different soils and then all
the market analysis will be very
different whether we have an inoculant
carrying material or whether we put
something and large amounts to row crops
so that that will be very different and
I'm sure it will the opportunities will
vary and and not be Universal by any
means thank you very much for attention
I'm happy to take any questions that you
might have time for thank you the volume
originally yeah yeah so that's that's a
big fight that luckily as a soil
scientist I don't have to partake but
it's a it's not known their c14 ages
that go up to eight nine thousand years
so some of them are pretty old some of
them are just five hundred plus and
there's really I've not seen any c14
dates that are more recent than five
hundred years ago simply for the fact
because we were very efficient in and
right yeah this was all we've brought
pigs and we brought influenza and that
was that
and so we there are supposedly there are
some some reports of indigenous
populations are still producing Terra
Preta and biochar but it's a bit
contentious some say it's really a
by-product of habitation accidental from
how they lived and what they swept some
say this can't be true and we've
calculated that although also through
you cannot have from from fire and
burning the black carbon amounts that we
today find even slash and burn if you do
the numbers what we find today cannot be
created by slash and burn or or fires or
kitchen fires it's impossible there
needs to be some purposeful addition
about what that was and and whether they
recognized that this was something they
should do is remains a mystery for us
luckily we know when they were added we
can measure it now it doesn't matter but
the archaeologists are are in a much
tougher spot because they need to
explain it
yeah that's a big question also and and
the numbers in newspaper articles go
from zero point zero zero something to
10 percent and anything in between not
known I so
circumstantial evidence is that you you
can get out of the car almost anywhere
and ask somebody about tariff rate and
they within fifteen twenty minutes
they've guide you to somewhere where
there is one but then sometimes they're
only half a hectare quarter of a hectare
the big ones are underlying the big
cities of Manaus sauntering in billing
there are several hundred hectares large
so if you if you get the chance on
drilling through some of the floorboards
and the big downtown houses then you
find Terra Preta underneath but we don't
know my best guess is that it's less
than a percent so it's not it's not half
it's I don't think it's ten percent but
that's just my guess yeah
well the the process is exothermic so
you're actually gaining energy but what
you're losing is of course mass it's
similar to to a fire in the fireplace at
home you you need activation energy
which is the match or a lighter but once
it's starting it has enough energy to
perpetuate the the process oh if you if
you let the machine run 24/7 you know
it's it's nothing it's a fraction of a
percent it's it's absolutely nothing if
you if you ramp it up and down every day
then I don't know what it would be but
you would never do that in a commercial
facility so once you once you provide
the activation energy you and you have
gas recycling then it just is driven by
your own off gases but if you're only
producing Bachar you're you're wasting
70% of the energy 50% of the carbon and
most of the hydrogen and oxygen why why
this makes from a systems perspective
why this makes sense to think about it
is because while you're actually or for
for us as agricultural minded person
people is that you're you're retaining
half of the carbon roughly while and put
it back in the soil
well while volatilizing 90% of the
hydrogen and oxygen know that that you
don't have maybe a lot of use in the
soil anyways as water and co2 so so it
makes sense to to look at this from a
life cycle perspective because you can
get 70% 80% of the energy out of the
biomass while retaining half of the
carbon as a soil amendment so that's
that's a starting point why why this
looks like from a life cycle perspective
looks like a good idea yeah
yeah none whatsoever
but very good question that's that would
be a good title for a project
excellent Tyler for a project yeah I I
have no idea whatsoever I there are
there are some researchers in in
Connecticut they are looking at
asparagus for instance onion that that
looks very promising they they find very
good results in the Midwest on the Molly
Souls we would not expect any positive
results but they're looking at different
withdrawal regimes they're comparing
with and without biochar additions at
80% residue removal for bioenergy 50%
and they think that they would be able
to maintain carbon levels in soil with
higher removal because of the the
biochar we've done we're in our sixth
year on Atmos grave fear up the road and
in Aurora an added biochar we've seen no
positive effect on on yield and we
didn't really expect we see a slight
improvement in nitrogen retention and
nitrogen and reduction of nitrogen
losses by leaching and and and
denitrification but no improvement in
and crop yields with corn so we have a
little hatch grant where we want to try
out maybe 30 different soils from
upstate New York and see whether which
kind of biochar works on which kind of
soil so that's that's a first step
towards that and we have a couple of
different projects in in Africa where we
do that as well with the magnet
foundations for instance to try out that
for Ethiopia and look at at a gradient
of different soils and try out what soil
constraints there might be and what
opportunities there are for biochar to
address those
Geneva do you have any questions that's
a good question we we calculated a
little bit through the because it's it's
attractive to look at the waste biomass
first and we looked at yard wastes and
and that looked fairly positive and I
will be will be interesting to start
something here in in Tompkins County
that are not very efficiently using
they're they're collected yard wastes
for for composting there are some
feedstock we don't have as many
feedstocks in upstate New York as for
instance some of the problematic
feedstocks that we're working with in
New Jersey is a poultry manure where we
see some some opportunities and in
earning also nutrient credits there's
one project in Pennsylvania and
Pennsylvania has a new nutrient
crediting program similar to a carbon
credit program where they get money for
getting phosphorous out of watersheds
and densification through pyrolysis is
is a good way to do that and still have
a marketable product so they are hoping
to earn nutrient credits by producing
biochar and and have still a marketable
product yeah so I it's it's a work in
progress I there's a lot of interest
from farmers and landscapers but
comprehensive analysis hasn't been done
good question though
yeah that will be a hmm yeah
there is not you can you can modify the
particle size it depends a lot on the on
the starting material if you put big
chunks in big chunks come out for many
feedstocks for some of the grasses you
can find powder no matter what you do
for fast pyrolysis you get fine powder
for slow pyrolysis you get slightly
coarser powder so there's there's all
that kind consideration very few
projects on as simple things as moisture
retention curves structural stability
aggregate stability penetration very
very few data there's one project that
funded by the NSF at Rice University
that looks at at moisture retention
curves we've done a little bit but but
not enough to really say anything about
it
there about maybe five papers out now
and and it's not no it's not conclusive
what they would be saying but we know
that any organic matter added to soil
improves typically field capacity and
and moisture retention that's usable
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu